hey guys so my pal Charlie Kirk was
coming through LA and I said you cannot
leave LA before you come into my studio
and hang out for at least half an hour
so we covered everything from 2020
politics to students for Trump to
religion and everything in between
charlie is the founder of TP USA he's
the head of Students for Trump he is the
host of the Charlie Kirk show the guy
does everything and I think he lives on
an airplane if you guys want to keep
saying more of this content let me know
and I'll invite more of my friends over
when they come through town enjoy
[Music]
I'm going on man hey Michael thanks for
having me I see you in any city that I'm
in that's where you are that's correct
you are you are in four cities a day I
think and you were living on an airplane
for the rest of that time yes I figured
out the the metaphysical impossibility
of being in one more than one place at
one cigarette you gotta let me know your
secret at some point yes uh it's anyway
thanks for having me huge fan I love
listen your podcasts there's very few
things I listen to oh listen to Russia
listen to Prager I listen to you I
listen to Ben
yeah it's daily wire rush Prager I
appreciate that I you know I actually
not to flatter you but I both want to
flatter you and admonish you because
usually you give me a lot of hope you're
flying all over the country you're
spreading this great message of love of
country and liberty and freedom I've
gone to a number of TP USA events I
always have a great time and then you
come out with this op-ed in Newsweek
that has me very worried because you say
that there are these sleeper cells of
socialists who could destroy our country
and nobody is paying sufficient
attention that's correct so I'm a
contrarian by Nature that's just who I
am
I suspected that yeah I got that
impression and so I I couldn't be a more
firm supporter of the President what
he's doing
I mean he's saving Western civilization
there's no doubt about it I mean his
policies has his worldview his he's
doing unbelievably well and I got I have
the Hat I don't have the Hat unfortunate
not so we should have had Matt he
deserves to be convincingly re-elected
in a 1972 or 1984 landslide yeah yeah
however he probably won't win in a
landslide like that so everywhere
because I think if the election were
held today he would win fifty seven
states okay yeah but you think there's a
more of a threat I've been on 37 states
right exactly um look so everywhere I go
people are telling me that Trump's gonna
win so when I mean everybody from
reporters to the to them from the New
York Times to GOP donors and especially
the donors and the equation works like
this is I like Trump what he's doing I
don't like his style everyone write that
okay if I'm sure they put that in the
box but I really hate the Democrats
Democrats are so radical therefore Trump
will win reelection this is the a plus
but you hear this
non-stop everywhere you go right and so
then I say to myself do I believe that
that's that so then I think I'm not just
gonna digest that pablum may might be
true there's Pavel and that's true
sometimes sure and so then I say what it
is is this correct and I say to myself
first of all um I think I think he
should win but he's up against a massive
media machine he's up against a social
media conglomeration that will do
everything they can to manipulate shut
him in the election and then finally
from base when I see addict totally and
what I see in the data I think there are
far more people that will embrace
radical left-wing ideology than we would
ever believe and so let's take the
college kids you speak at a lot of
college campuses you do it really well
you know this is what we do at Turning
Point USA every single day do most of
the college activists that protest you
or protest me you think they're gonna go
and support Joe Biden I mean some might
but they would be out in droves to
support Elizabeth Warren yeah and Bernie
Sanders so I think it's fair to say that
if Elizabeth Warren or Sanders gets
nominated someone of that ilk there'd be
boosted turnout amongst younger voters
well boost the turnout on campus throws
off all the voter models right one of
the main reasons why Hillary Clinton won
in 2016 is lower than usual voter
turnout you use voter turnout right and
she had a lot a good dead voter turnout
that's what he didn't have a ton of
youth vote yes so she spiked she spiked
the deceased she did quite well in the
deceased community I think Epstein's
gonna vote for her though I take the
fifth so but so look I that there are
people like they were hidden Trump
voters I believe there's hidden
socialist voters out there yeah I think
this country is more way further the
left than we ever realized and I and we
want to admit just take how many people
vote for the Green Party if you add the
Green Party plus Hillary Clinton's
deficit in Wisconsin she's president you
know there's this thing that Hemingway
described he was describing Ernest
Hemingway or Molly honey did not I wish
it were Molly but this is earnest and
like what earnest said is he was
describing someone going bankrupt and he
said it happened gradually then suddenly
mm-hmm and I think that's what's
happening with such a Hemingway
it's a yeah very Pippi has climax it has
trow it pros and then boom and then it
hits you exactly this I think is what's
happening with radicalism you know you
you see these same polls more than half
of young Americans identify as
socialists even though only about thirty
percent can define what socialism is
five years ago if you had told me that a
man can really be a woman and that most
Americans would think a man can really
be we I'd laugh in your face nobody
would believe yes and yet because of the
results of a cultural revolution that's
going on and on and on these days if you
say that a man cannot be a woman you
could be kicked off that's correct you
could lose your job you could be kicked
out of school
things happen gradually then suddenly so
what does this mean for 2020 or we at
the suddenly press so I think it's an
inflection point I still think Trump is
gonna win and I'm in at everything in
Canada I'm gonna do everything I can to
make sure he wins yeah but I I don't
like all of a sudden taking victory laps
fourteen months ahead of an election
which I figure is if that's the tone of
the movement right now I can't go to one
place out someone saying that Trump is
gonna win yeah I can't I can't find that
gathering and I was like this is not
this is first of all that's not that's
not there's no way to win first of all
yeah I mean just just ask Buster Douglas
okay Buster Douglas Mike Tyson 42 to one
odds okay you think you're gonna win and
all of a sudden you lose in Tokyo you're
okay and if and everyone if that's above
your head good okay I love sports I
think sports are a great metaphor for I
know I'm the only one we don't allow on
this show is soccer but I guess that's a
conversation for another time correct
yeah I'd say it's let the Europeans
figure out how to tie how could you tie
in this point how could and as soon as
the NFL brought into tying they also
brought in kneeling that I know direct
correlation and I think no conspiracy
collusion that's right allusion against
the the anti meritocracy culture that
the left is trying to create so look
here's the thing I try to I'm trying to
offer some sobriety to our movement
first of all I think the left is gonna
be more to determine than ever then
defeat Donald Trump I think there's more
socialists on the fringe they're gonna
show up at a pure hatred to destroy this
guy yeah and I think the we have to win
the Democrats don't have to lose that's
a big difference if we're counting on
winning because of how bad they are
we're going to lose we have to go for
the jugular we have to and
metaphorically
jugular okay auntie for media matters
people whatever I know you're there
writing the media matters hit a piece on
your qualifying it okay right
and then of for go for the jugular okay
when auntie foot literally goes for the
jaw
okay that we have to sit we have to say
so boldly and definitively who we are as
a country what is this country stand for
the the whole Trump doctrine the Mogga
doctrine if you do what is it what is
the magazine and I have the book coming
out in February actually I can't wait is
that for us yeah that was really good
right there right in the strike zone the
mega Doctrine is this number one you
have to you have to admit one thing
America is the greatest country ever to
exist in the history of the world that's
number one you don't admit that you got
some other doctrines missus some Iranian
doctrine or something right it's not
rather with us or a guy exactly if you
believe that you believe in something
else but I don't know what what it is
but you have the first lay out number
two you have to believe America has been
heading in the wrong direction generally
in the last thirty years hmm it's post
Donald Regan so to to both parties both
parties have been equally contributing
to this those are the two things you
believe those two things welcome to the
mago doctrine because then you have to
believe that if we've been heading in
the wrong direction and we are the
greatest country then a revitalization
is necessary now understanding that a
revitalization is historically
improbable because we're taught in
history class that usually there's the
arca civilizations right so there's this
general upward trajectory and then you
have a little dip and then you have a
smaller surgeons and in total decline
well then historians would say the
eighties was our resurgence right like
Reagan was the great again moment but to
have two great again moments has that
ever happened
so Trump is going up against the
historical impossibility to try to fight
the endless wars the corrupt politicians
essentially cicero's Rome is really what
you'll decay exactly Malaya and so what
what is the Magadh doctrine it is what
set of policies can i implement that
have proven to be timeless and hit in
the history of civilization to fight
back the decay of civilizations number
one strong borders and recognition of
sovereignty number two a vibrant
american working class number three
ending the endless wars declaring war in
a country that looks us us at a silly is
the dumbest thing and Trump is doing
this spectacularly well over overseas
what he's doing and in the Afghanistan
war but even he's had trouble getting
out of Afghanistan out of Syria because
because look the permanent military
class wants us to be in these endless
wars where there's if you came
find victory why are you engaged in the
conflict if you can't define a goal you
were right and why you asked these
five-star generals what is what does
success look like well we have to fight
them there so don't fight them here well
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
I mean that no wait could you create a
foreign policy around fighting every
enemy around the world on their own
terrain so anyway the final thing is
this and this is the most important
thing is an unapologetic defense of our
cultural icons symbols values and
traditions that's how you you revitalize
a country so the manga doctrine is a
revitalization almost a resuscitation of
a country that was so going in the wrong
direction cultural decline economic
decline and so he's turned around the
economy he's defended our core objects
and symbols our flag our tradition our
symbol salutely I know I'm probably my
favorite thing that he's done is he's
actually spoken at a fundamental and
cultural level about the things that we
hold dear is against the things that we
hold sacred together the flag our
national history totally our founding
fathers against a whole leftist culture
and that's that tries to tear it down
let me tell you another thing that he
holds near and dear is that we are the
best and we should own it on her sleeve
there's a hierarchy of nations and we
are the greatest country out there were
the strongest we're the mightiest we'd
the biggest army but guess what we're
also the most generous the most
benevolent the most creative most likely
to send people when there's a hurricane
a tsunami an earthquake or a flood we
step up it's not the Belgians iced over
the most charitable country in the
history of the world there's no doubt
and so so that's what the magadh
doctrine is and I think we have to talk
in terms of you know you and I that
really get into the nuts and bolts the
philosophy on the economics of all this
I think he doesn't get enough credit for
what he's actually done philosophically
and and and on the policy side and going
going in 2020 it's going to be a it's
been gonna be a referendum on they'd be
of America so referendum on the idea of
America in a sense are we a nation of
victims or a nation of victors are we
are we thankful that we live in America
are we angry that we live in America do
we love our country do we hate our
country but that's basically it right
and so if Trump frames the debate like
this yeah he will win he will win he
will win I think decisively and
assertively and I think but recognizing
that the country we live today is not
the country in 1984 not the Orwellian
1984 but the Reagan versus Mondale 1980
right but so the question is what kind
of election are we headed for
the conventional wisdom and Republican
circles it boy this feels like 1972
we're a much different country than we
were in 1972 okay right we have more
kids going to indoctrination factories
demography we've changed tremendously
the welfare state is much bigger the
public schools have more of an increase
so the idea that we're gonna win a 49
state landslide and we're running into
George McGovern who is whatever or
Walter Mondale an 84 I know I don't
accept the premise of course I mean you
can even look at the Supreme Court
confirmations right when you have
Supreme Court nominees of either party
being confirmed by virtually unanimous
support right until Robert Bork and then
even after Robert Bork you get a certain
you know this is something a great point
it's such a great point okay so now but
they're the left is the only one that
demagogues Supreme Court nominees when
was the last time I mean Merrick garland
was the only time that a Republican
stood up but thank goodness Mitch
McConnell is I did with Harambee but
miss McConnell did the correct thing
with Merrick garland that's the only
exception but Bork and Cavanaugh I mean
boy do they cause trouble and anyone's
Thomas my goodness they try to publicly
destroy him and Clarence Thomas's own
words you know I mean this was a pub
who's a modern day lynching high-tech
lynching that's correct right and they
do it be President Trump just the other
day he took aim what we all suspected he
was taking aim at was Sean Hannity who's
a friend of his but Hannity was covering
for Chris Chris Cuomo on CNN because
Cuomo was accosted in public and Hannity
said oh you know company was called Nero
or something it was crazy yeah what was
that word I don't know word right afraid
I call them near as a joke cuz I mean I
would say that if in Italian it'd be
worse to be called Nero than fret I mean
I would be upset if someone called me
Nero and that is literally the Italian
n-word that you just made a great point
you're right that is the Italian n-word
I mean it's actually the Italian say
that word Nero that's our word Charlie
that's our word what you Catholics are
you Italians yes okay yes sure no we own
all history we are the Catholic Church
okay right yeah I know I love your
Martin Luther thing by the way do you
like we're gonna have a whole
theological debate here I know I love a
good rebellion against the corrupt
institution do you know I always try to
be ecumenical I invite even Martin
Luther to my set I'm a living
one of them you are at a living
embodiment of this I actually I read a
communion after or I actually I even
it's pains me to do it I want to pay a
compliment to at the expense of the
Catholic Church to the Protestants okay
in this country the only religious group
that reliably votes the right way are
the evangelicals it's not the Catholics
you know why why is that because they
read the Bible they do read the Bible
more that's true well you know I you
know what I actually think I think how
kidding might I have my family's
Catholic I have great respect for the
Catholic Church in the Catholic
tradition
I really do I don't know a great point
because this is my issue with the
Catholics in America
half the Catholics in America they say
they're Catholic and yet they support
abortion and now these days it's
abortion up until the moment of birth
the guy in New York the governor
Democratic Governor Andrew Cuomo
who allowed for abortion up until the
moment of birth nominally is a Catholic
now that's because they say we're
culturally Catholic whereas you don't
see a whole lot of people who are
culturally evangelical you gotta kind of
I call these people chinos Catholics and
name on like it yes Catholics in name
only what do you I mean you're worried
about the socialist sleeper cells
yes worried about even beyond the
cultural level at the religious left
sure we've got talked at length about
this you've got a whole generation of
young Americans yeah who are there not
even atheists there none there Annihilus
ly unaffiliated roll on they've been
raised in a nihilistic culture that's
correct
is there any hope for America if we
don't turn around that religious decline
it's hard the answer is more complicated
than yes or no um it's hard to see it's
hard to see without a strong religious
backbone how this country will continue
to succeed right that what may look this
country is so unique we take it so for
granted but we are the most diverse
country ever to exist in the history of
the world and not just racial diversity
about religious diversity I mean and
this is this is so critically important
because when when look the the amount of
whether it be Protestantism or
Catholicism or Judaism or what Islam or
whatever that you could practice in this
country
we're Marianne Williamson ISM I don't
know why whatever after yeah do you have
to do of crystals do I
got my chakras sitar music or a shaman
think she was a shaman in a previous
life force if you don't know what a
shaman is look it up look the the chert
and look I will I will pay a huge amount
of compliment to the Catholic tradition
because if it wasn't for the Catholics
on we obviously wouldn't have the Bible
and two of my favorite writers Aquinas
and Agustin obviously we're in the
Catholic tradition yeah and I think that
we could learn a lot of our foreign
policy doctrine from Aquinas to Just War
Theory right and I think that we've
strayed away from that and that we've
gotten to an offensive war theory and I
think that is a really big devolution
but of course you know the binary choice
of the City of God in the City of Man
which I can if there's a customer
Aquinas I can't remember which one City
of God is a suggestion
it was rig Austin okay yeah I get that
going confused there's a but there also
weren't to say we're also big fan one
was fan of the other because one came
800 years before the other yeah but
anyway the point being is that um to
answer your question about America the
the role of the church and the role of
religious institutions is so uniquely
American because Europe has has turned
their back run on voluntary social
construct institutions yeah so instead
they go to compulsory social constructs
institutions institutions the government
bureaucracy and so just from a
charitable standpoint as the church
decreases in its role and stature in
America it contributes to a moral
decline and where the church is at its
best is being able to distill really
hard cultural issues and take definitive
stances on yeah and look look no further
in the 1980s I mean people like to say
the the alliance of Maggie Thatcher and
Ronald Reagan but people forget hold on
a second there was john paul ii right
who was also a huge anti-communist and
when he went to poland i mean he was he
he helped sow the seeds of the end of
the Soviet Venera massed million people
in the England we want god that's right
that was the chant imagine if you had
that because he was a freedom fighting
pope and he gets no credit for it and
and importantly to he wrote about the
evils of socialism he talks about he in
his catechism he wrote about it need and
and he wrote in a famous encyclical
chant as a moose honors he wrote about
free markets open markets a leo xiii
another great pope called so
ilysm a wicked Confederacy called them
pests said it was inhuman said that it
must be utterly resisted and yet these
days from Pope Francis hath liqu leaders
and some other other Protestant leaders
you see an embrace an idea that Jesus
was some kind of hippie social I'm so
glad you brought this up and this is
something that I'm gonna take on more
and more personally in a couple projects
you know I've talked about this yeah
which is look the I meet more and when i
go to and i and i'm and i'm in amman
Jellicle so you know our we are we have
church service more than an hour so when
I go to yeah when I go to the Latin one
I'll go on yeah right on an hour right
that's you just right there only
seven-minute like if it goes if it goes
more than seven minutes or not there's
not price it depends on the priest some
you want it to go for two hours some
like about four minutes and it's like
too much actually and so maybe they
bring it down to three that's great now
I I have great respect for the Catholic
tradition but anyway you know I'll go to
I I travel a lot and I'll go to a lot of
different Protestant churches but I love
for me I'm actually contrarian in the
Semite rich selection go figure I find
more intimacy in mega churches so I like
really really big churches I just I
actually find more of a connection it's
kind of that old Gatsby thing the best
place to feel you know to either most
lonely place in the world the most
connected place in the world can be in a
big party yeah yeah and so I love I love
the lights and I love the praise I love
it I just about the music I might such a
big fan okay don't song music the Buffum
usik all for it isn't that Hillsong guy
like an atheist now or something that
was one of the praise leaders that's a
that will pray for him right answer but
look so I'll go and I'll mingle
afterwards and I'll tell you Michael the
young the young churchgoers there's a
lot of left wingers and a lot of
socialists that are amongst this yea
Evangelical Protestant community and
this is really really really concerning
because it is the it is the corruption
of theology for political means and so I
like to say I go to I grew up in the
Presbyterian Church and I grew up in the
more leftist part the press train George
the divide it's the FPC a and FPC USA
right I get them confused
but one of them super liberal one of
them is pretty good I grew up another
liberal and so I went five years ago and
I felt like
I was watching Rachel Maddow with organ
music it was it was it was like watching
MSNBC you know while in-between
scripture readings where they would say
all political stuff basically you know
we have to pray for our country I'm it's
horrible president and all this sort of
stuff and then they would use theology
and scripture to justify that it was
really bizarre no I do have a little bit
of hope on this though because I agree I
was raised in in the Catholic Church
which became very left-wing openly
left-wing especially after vatican ii
and you had a watering down of the
liturgy and you had a lot of kind of
feel-good stuff the theologian Reinhold
Niebuhr described it as a God without
wrath leading a people without sin and
you love your German theologian yes sir
there you go through the ministrations
of a Christ with that across and this
kind of soapy religion I think chased a
lot of people away sure now when I go to
church because you're a lot of Catholic
masses are like 45 minutes 15 I'm saying
it's the pee it's the drive by but you
know you go to those and when I go into
those I find it's the blue hairs it's
the older people it's there aren't a lot
of people in there anyway a lot of
people aren't going to the sacraments
the priest is telling jokes like a ham
actor then I go to the Latin myths Latin
mess in a language that nobody reads
anymore it's an hour and a half long
it's got smells and bells it's actually
you have to go to confession you're
there there's a real encouragement of
the sacraments it's all the young people
it's the average age is probably 25 and
somehow they've all got ten kids already
I don't know how that mathematically I
don't even know how that works this
seems to me that there is at least at a
small level this longing among young
people for reality for order for order
for orthodoxy for Ruth and I you know
you go to these college campuses I go to
college yeses we'll just say basic
truths I gave a talk at University of
missouri-kansas city was called men are
not women
that's about as basic as it gets people
fill the room why did they do it because
in a culture that's gone mad with
fantasy with delusion yeah saccharine
sentiment people longed for the simple
states correct of reality you know I
think Trump does this very well that's
that's exactly right and so to the other
point about kind of the this is
something that we
to encounter head-on is within our own
Christian ranks and the Catholic Church
has already gone through this and I
think it's actually coming back but the
evangelical ranks we have not lived
through this yet and we're starting to
see it through some fights in the
Southern Baptist Convention we're seeing
my brother's word that it's becoming
left it's becoming very leftist yeah and
there's open conversations like well
Jesus was socialists hold on a second
Jesus is not a Marxist okay and what you
and I could talk at length about this
parable the talents he tested politics
he was savior of the world not running
for Roman Council my logic of the
universe yeah it's just minor
theological differences in details but I
mean even the the scene when he
chastises his followers for criticizing
his having expensive perfume put on
mm-hmm that's not just that that that
scene alone should should dismiss this
silly modern Marxist view yes of hippie
socialists Jesus well he was also
speaking individuals helping individuals
and the individual's pathway to the
salvation so what what gets misconstrued
and I'm not misconstrued I think is
actually just bigoted they intentionally
misinterpret the theology because you
actually go back you read John for
example go back to the original Greek
there's no way you could possibly
interpret it as such where the the left
will try to say well Jesus was talking
in terms of collective and all this he
really wasn't I mean you turned out a
lot of his parables he was talking as
you as the individual so the Good
Samaritan you have to go outside of your
comfort zone to help somebody but you
might not want to help like that's it's
not go call DHS and they're gonna you
know come and some bureaucrats gonna go
do good for you or I don't I must have
missed the parable or I must miss to the
the part in the gospel where Jesus said
you know go form a government
bureaucracy and you know you know I have
a committee that meets from 9:00 to 5:00
every day pool your resources why in a
widely inefficient way I must have
missed that you know it occurs to me
you're speaking obviously very in
religious terms and this is traditional
for conservatives especially in that
post-war conservative movement you had
the libertarians the traditionalists a
religious right you had the communism
Hawks they were all against this this
common enemy which was the Soviet Union
the cold war ends then what what does
the conservative movement looked like
such a great question so the the Soviet
Union kept them all together is what
that's why Reagan was able to build this
coalition in 1980 and take over the
party that he wasn't supposed to ever be
at the nominee of right
I mean in 76 Reagan tried to overthrow
sitting president Gerald Ford in 1976
and he got to the convention floor and
sort of half endorsed him didn't really
endorse him but Reagan was a rebel and
the reason why rate people thought
Reagan was gonna lose in a landslide to
Jimmy Carter and he won surprisingly
sound familiar mmm and then all of a
sudden he was the one that crushed the
Soviet Union so what is our Soviet Union
today well it's the left in our country
the Soviet Union's no longer
headquartered in Moscow there in Montana
Michigan Mississippi and Missouri
they're everywhere and only on the
University campuses right well it's a
center and then I'm in Hollywood and all
this other so so look the the coalition
that we have to build though yeah that
Reagan got correct and Trump gets
correct and I feel that our movement
gets wrong so often is we have to break
and you understand is we have to break
our shackles away from these coastal
elitist than at universities and these
think tanks that think that if you're a
carpenter a pipe fitter or you didn't go
to four-year college or somehow less
than worthy to have be engaged in the
American conversation right that's what
Reagan was successful
that's where Trump is successful and I
feel as if there's this elitism that
permeates our movement where all of a
sudden that if you didn't go to the
correct University in the upper
Northeast Corridor right any opinion you
have is what well it's deplorable it's
all this and the left says it our people
don't so you know what it is it's also
an emperor has no clothes in the
situation because having gone to one of
those correct universities in the
northeast corner and I did go to one of
them and you didn't go to one of them I
didn't go to any you didn't go to any of
them but you do have an honorary degree
yes from Liberty and for Liberty
everybody should go to the University
yes but you know having gone there I can
kind of see what's happened to it
what the left has done to these
universities which is to hollow them out
from within so it's not to say that
there's nothing to be gained at any of
these places but what it is to say is
the institution that's hobbling around
and it looks like Harvard or Yale and it
talks like Harvard or Yale it isn't what
it used to be the left has gone on a
long
through the institutions and so what you
are getting in the end is something
that's simply not as academically
serious scholarly scholar Lilly rigorous
you're not getting that same quality of
education so you have whole generations
who are uneducated uncultured you know
they're so damn convinced that they're
the smartest people that they're hyper
credentialed hyper credentialed so they
have all the degrees but they know
nothing right and they often have a lot
of student debt right so they're they're
they're in debt they're vulnerable and
they have degrees up the wazoo and they
there's no wisdom there's no knowledge
there's no history no perspective no
humility no definitely not they're
constantly wrong but they're never in
doubt that's exactly and so so you you
mix all this together so look here's
what the movement moving forward is
number one we have to dominate and the
Libertarians I know you and I might not
see eye to eye on all this a little I'm
a little less liberal but I I do see the
point do we I mean this is my question -
sure
do we need to hold together the exact
same cold no we have to rebuild a new
one okay
and so my coalition is number one I
think we have to libertarians I think
those are ours to get these guys hate
government your personal freedom and
there's converse there's robust
conversations we can have but all that
sort of stuff there's stuff that we
should not compromise on so like a
pro-choice libertarian sorry not gonna
happen right but like if you want to go
put some substance in your body that
I've never done and I don't even know
where to find go ahead like I don't care
right so there's long as you have some
to share yeah what you don't need I'm
saying so that that's one libertarians
those are our people okay we shouldn't
lose that number two is is any sort of
person that goes to has religion as a
core part of their their their day or
their their life their identity that
that's these are our people yeah okay
and they should be actually four or five
number three the other part of the
coalition is people that wake up before
7:00 a.m. I'm not kidding every human
being in America that wakes up before
7:00 a.m. should be a Republican well
that's good and then we should limit the
vote to be over at about 8:00 a.m. and
then we win there I'm not kidding and I
say that somewhat jokingly but if you're
getting up early and you really got a
you got to really muster some strength
to go to work you're you're one of us I
don't care if you're a carpenter a
teacher a pipe fitter you're not a left
this Stephen a hedge fund manager no
okay of course but again there's there
50 of them okay that's fine but I'm
talking of the fifty thousand teachers
in Missouri that we've never talked to
and they're working their tail off right
I think I'm this comes to this hyper
elitism so if you're waking up early and
you got a really fight and you got to do
your are people like that's I want our
party yummy the world that the hard work
nation party that's us the final thing
is is the doctrinaire conservatives and
and there's about eight or ten million
of these people and they're the ones
that listen the band they listen to Rush
and you know they're the Tea Party folks
they buy all the books those are our
folks I love those people right and
that's our coalition okay if you combine
libertarians which are generations
coming in recent libertarian religious
hard-working conservatives that's sixty
five million people you'll win any
election you can with that let them go
after all the people that will sleep
until ten and do whatever the hell they
want it like I don't care about those
people right I do care about them I
don't care about their votes like I
don't wanna build a cook let me make
myself good I care about them as people
I don't like I don't want to build a
political party around people that sleep
all day and do nothing
of course yeah and they're not really
reliable when you need to go out and
knock on doors but you know what I'm
saying it's right that that's a movement
I think that can have robust debate and
can be and could be one that can win the
future and make our country a better
place looking at 2020 it looks to me
there are three big vulnerabilities one
is that Hillary Clinton is a uniquely
detestable candidate and so if even
someone like Joe Biden who I think is a
total doofus even he is like I don't
know he's Elvis Presley compared to
Hillary Clinton I mean even he is a
pretty cool guy you got that you have
the prospect of economic difficulty I
mean we've had an incredibly long bull
run obviously we're engaged in a tough
trade war with China right now there is
the prospect that the economy falters
and three the wall we will promised a
big beautiful wall we want the big
beautiful wall well we all want the wall
and yet there is not yet new border wall
though there may be because of that
Supreme Court decision that allowed for
a hundred miles that might get some of
it built before 2020 but more likely not
are those vulnerabilities insurmountable
no they're not instrumental you don't
think any if the economy tanks well I'm
not if I don't think it will but if the
economy tanks I still think Trump can
win okay but I don't think the economy
will mean the fundamentals are too good
and so look we have we have a community
of economic hypochondriacs so I mean
this were a good way to put it where
these people are trying to convince
themselves that there's a recession
mm-hmm and so you know what the profit
hypochondriacs are eventually you're
gonna get sick because you're trying to
get sick you're right and at least
eventually you're gonna be right what
that means right exactly
mommy I'm sick no you're not go to
school mommy I'm sick Milly not go to
school okay finally the 95th time you
actually might have the flu yeah but
here's the thing is the funny thing
about recessions is you can talk
yourself into a recession I mean
remember if you read von mises human
action I mean that's all the economy is
it's it's multi trillions inputs of
human action put into one thing that we
call the economy right there's no such
thing you can't touch the economy every
little piece is the economy right but
all of a sudden you have ten million
people that change their behavior then
all of a sudden you can create a
recession and that's what they're trying
to do they're trying to propagandize the
American public to create a recession
ahead of this Bill Maher said it would
be worth or research that's correct to
kick Trump ass you know what that means
that he wants to see people suffer yeah
cuz that's how much he hates Donald
Trump yeah he wants to see people that
wake up over 7:00 a.m. in Idaho and in
Illinois he wants to see them have a
horrible Christmas yeah so that he can
make sure that he can be right at a
cocktail party and guess what we're for
Bill Maher out there he would be fine in
a recession of people will keep coming
to his stupid comedy routine people will
still be watching his show he'll be just
fine I mean you but guess who won't be
fine the people that Donald Trump who
has maids live their lives better
no of course and so look I I don't think
there might be an economic slowdown I
think that's possible
I look I think that the bigger I think
there's of course there I think the left
is gonna try to throw some surprises and
I think China's gonna heavily try to
interview at this election so look I
think China through their proxies
through North Korea through any sort of
way that they can jab at Trump and make
him look not in reality would make him
look wrong they're gonna do it you think
that Russia interfere in our election
through a couple troll farms just waits
you'll see what China's gonna try it and
you know historically speaking this is
something the left doesn't understand
throughout the Cold War we would play
China off Russia and roth's Russia off
of China and so when Russia was the big
we would have maybe open up China go
play some ping-pong with them play them
off of Russia now it would seem that
China's the bigger threat we might play
Russia off of China and yet then we're
told these people have been Russian dubs
for a hundred years that's right since
the run revolutionized for their support
of the Soviet imeem but least ever since
the Russian Revolution a hundred years
ago they've been telling us Russia is no
big deal so the Union I've seen the
future and it works and and now the one
time that Russia is actually a
de-emphasized role now Russia I mean if
you actually look at the Russian model
right now they have an aging population
yeah they have one-third our pot our
population they have huge social
problems I mean just real big social
problems they produce next to nothing I
mean they don't they just produce those
dolls inside the little doll exactly and
if there was less of a threat than they
ever have been now do I think we should
be double shun China no I rush I'm like
no but now all the sudden they're the
Russia Hawks right now they're worried
about Russia like Adam Schiff are you
serious meanwhile you have China who is
cheating on our trade deals illegally
subsidizing they're about to mow down
Hong Kong Muslims in concentration camps
so quiet the left is when China locks up
Muslims in constant actual concentration
camps yeah not holding the town because
they're not in Arizona so well that's
right but those aren't real
concentration Springs but but the other
thing that's really interesting about so
for you kind of go through what I call
first they tried to say they try to say
well it's the Russian collusion that
didn't work and they tried the racism
stuff that didn't work another trying
the recession thing you know throw all
the ours right yeah and it's going to
the thing that is so improbable at the
Trump presidency is his ability to
withstand adversity I mean if you and I
were doing this show eight months ago
all we'd be talking about is Baba molar
and we it's mother time but like we just
forget about him alert I mean all we
talked about is the bottom two freakin
years and no I can't turn on the cable
news Rachel Maddow
what happened like all she talked about
was Bob Muller for two years it doesn't
remember his own name at that
congressional testimony because now and
we are so bad at this as conservatives
because we're filled with the holy
spirit and we believe in mercy
forgiveness atonement and all these
great things we just move on we should
we should seek revenge for them for what
they've done to us
are you kidding me this is the book of
charlie no but like III feel you man
I am and this I'm struggling I'm having
I'm having a very serious you know human
and divine struggle here because I
should forgive the left but I'm at part
of the know well you know what it is are
you kidding me well I'll give you a
little Sicilian advice revenge is a dish
best served cold that's why I got a
serve in November 2012 speaking of that
before I let you go give me a horse head
and somebody's gonna be I need to know
you're speaking of horses your horse
race bets on the 2020 Democrats who gets
it who's rising could any of the Biden
will not be the nominee you don't think
so
I think Warren will be the nominee
Warren is raising the raising a ton of
money on a wampum John Wall so you have
to hierarchy of what the left ones
number thing they want they want to be
Donald Trump that's the only reason why
Biden was up in the polls Warren is
surging because she's starting to make
the argument that she can be Donald
Trump yeah um she's angry all the time
but she's good she's she's she's like
thoughtful angry right she's not she's
not um she's not marrying it Mary Ann
Williams and angry where she's often
some sort of extraterrestrial existence
right she's you don't really understand
what I'm saying but if you understood it
then go to Marianne Williamson dot-com
and put in your horoscope harness kind
of exactly Chris yes you should have her
on the show that would be I would love
it so but the other thing is that she
she gets she's more populist and more as
more grassroots energy than most of the
other Democrats and I think that will
prove to be very valuable it's amazing
that a Harvard Law Professor the whitest
woman to ever live who pretends to be an
Indian for 30 years she and I agree with
you she genuinely does have a more so
she's a follower grant she legit and I
think Bernie will fade away and I think
Bernie will name her as the heir
apparent of his brother stole all his
plans right exactly well she has a plan
for that too but I think um I I don't
think it'll be Biden he has no spirit he
has no charisma is no stamina
he's a total gaffe machine there's more
in pose a threat to try I mean yes
instinctively I say no but yes yet you
have to take everybody seriously yeah if
they nominated pute at judge if they
nominated robert francis O'Rourke every
one of them posing what about Eric's
whoa well he's all of us what so he's
the biggest threat of all she dropped
out yeah he's he's really spectacular
but look you have to take
all of them seriously what I'm saying
and I say this is a as probably one of
the most loyal living human beings / -
right okay I mean you're wrong for tribe
that I named as loyal as it gets I'm
also trying to be honest with the
followers in the audience there's all of
them we have to take seriously yeah
Elizabeth Warren will play for keeps
she'll do whatever it takes the left
will do whatever it takes and if we
begin for a micron to underestimate the
left yeah yeah oh my goodness forget
about it like for instance if we think
that Elizabeth Warren gave us something
she would take it back I don't remember
what the term is for that but she would
do it she absolutely would do it now
you're out there fighting hard every
single day I always love going to TP USA
thank you we got a lot off we got a lot
of warriors you got a lot of warriors
you got it you got a big one coming up
into several things that I'll
shamelessly plug please that's what you
do on shows like this first thought do
it should by a leftist tears mug I'll
plug your thing yeah number one you can
go to Charlie Creek show and Apple
podcast please press subscribe if you
like what you have to hear if you've
heard please do that number two we have
our Turning Point USA event in December
it's our student action summit what
thousands of thousands it's an amazing
event I had such a good time last year
it's a blast
thank you a tipi us a.com slash i say
yes and look we're on the frontlines of
the culture war and i'm also running
students for trump which is an non
turning-point USA thing it's a turning
point action thing 501 C 4 organizations
so I'm gonna be running that look I was
a disclaimer for all the lawyers and
that's what I'm saying right for all the
people all the media matters trolls I
try to say that I'm not careful at that
stuff that was just for you but look we
gotta get this president reelected it's
the most important in our lifetime
there's gonna be moments where like this
is where we either saved or we've lost
the country and that's what one of these
things are and remember you hear it well
this is the most important election or a
lifetime do you know why you're able to
say that each time because because we
get further and further away from our
founding vision right and that's why
it's so important we win this election
and you're playing a huge role in thank
you for your thank you for your
compliments towards our president
because it doesn't go unnoticed and we
need more of it and this this president
is saved in Western society and just
together we're gonna help them
everywhere we can't you know I've worn
my hat all the way out so I need to go
buy a new hat good early thanks you are
the man then go check out the charlie
Kirk show and I look forward I think I'm
gonna be on that soon too yeah so I
can't wait we'll do this but I'm sitting
at the chair I'll be interviewing but
yeah you'll be sitting under you'll be
on an airplane somewhere say America
Charlie Kirk everybody
you